which of these functions is odd
and so just let's remind ourselves what
it means for a function to be odd so i
have a function well they've already
used f g and h so i'll use j so function
j is odd if you evaluate j at some value
so let's say j of a and if you evaluate
that j
at the negative of that value and if
these two things are the negative of
each other then my function is odd if
these two things were the same if they
didn't have this negative here then it
would be an even function so let's see
which of these meet the criteria of
being odd so let's first let's look at f
of x so we could pick a particular point
so let's say when x is equal to two so
we get f of two
f of two is equal to two now what is f
of negative two f of negative two looks
like it is six
f of negative two is equal to 6. so
these aren't the negative of each other
in order for this to be odd f of
negative 2 would have had to be equal to
the negative of this would have had to
be equal to negative 2. so f of x f of x
is definitely not odd so all i did had
to do is find even one case that that
violated this constraint to be odd and
so i can see it's definitely not odd
now let's look at g of x
so let's look at g of x so i could use
use the same let's see when x is equal
to 2 we get g of 2 is equal to negative
7.
now let's look at when g is negative 2
so we get g of negative 2
g of negative 2 is also equal to
negative 7. so here we have a situation
and it looks like that's the case for
any x we pick that g of x is going to be
equal to g of negative x so g of x is
equal to g of negative x it's symmetric
around the y or i should say the
vertical axis right over here so g of x
is even
not odd so which of these functions are
definitely not g of x so our last hope
is h of x let's see if h of x seems to
meet the criteria
so if we i'll do it in this green color
so if we take h of 1 h of 1 and we can
look at it even visually so h of 1 gets
us right over here h of negative 1 seems
to get us an equal amount an equal
distance negative so it seems to fit for
1 for 2 well 2 is at the at the x axis
but that's definitely h of 2 is 0 h of
negative 2 is 0 but those are the
negatives of each other 0 is equal to
negative 0. if we go to say h of 4 h of
4 is this negative number
and h of negative 4 is seems to be a
positive number of the same magnitude so
once again this
is the negative of this so it looks like
this is indeed an odd function and
another way to visually spot an odd
function
is a function it's going to go through
the origin
and you could essentially flip it over
on both axes so if you flip this the
right half over over the left half and
then flip that over the horizontal axis
you are going to get this right over
here so you see here we're going up and
to the right here we're going to go down
and to the left and then you curve right
over there you curve up just like that
but the easiest way to test it is just
to do what we did look at a given x so
for example when x is equal to eight h
of eight looks like this number right
around eight h of negative eight looks
like it's pretty close to negative eight
so they seem to be the negative of each
other it sounds like a car crash just
happened outside anyway hopefully you
enjoyed that not the car crash the math
problem